hello it's me markiplier here with
another video of questionable quality
and by questionable quality I mean I
don't know how this one's gonna go I
kind of just thought this up on a whim
and I don't know if the results are
gonna meet expectations but then again
expectations are usually low so to
describe this idea and give you even
more trepidation on the fact that you
clicked on this video I'm going to be
going through various quote v.com
quizzes which if you know about quote V
you know they are of the greatest
quality and you can't be beat with their
discount quizzes so I'm going to go
through them and hopefully find my true
love both on the boyfriend side and the
girlfriend side because at this point
I'm so desperate I'll take anything
whatever you know I'm not even gonna
preface it any more because the more I
talk the more people leave so you are
youtuber boyfriend I am mium I am
youtuber boyfriend is that me oh thank
you for noticing
oh it's made with me I can't read these
memes I need to get my mean goggles on
here and let me put in my monocle hang
on one second here uh-huh uh-huh my god
that is an ancient meme [ __ ] is that oh
I still can't read it huh let me look
into this one nope yeah oh wait oh yeah
oh I found it oh yeah yeah okay it's a
waste of my time are you ready
ah sure I guess all right let's go red
green cuz green yeah singing and dancing
I like me some singing and dancing
that's pretty good babe big fate oh boy
alright how about the bottom one perfect
Brits popular hot cute someone every guy
once I mean if you had any action that
was gonna be me it's obviously gonna be
that one right guys who the [ __ ] is that
who are you what answered three out of
six questions correctly what does that
mean what do you mean correctly and I'm
shocked that I got him correct cuz there
are so many answers
that's right it was part of this thing
this this thing that retired at the ripe
age of not old okay yeah I got okay all
right all right okay I hate that that
guy his mr. beauty pie I know that guy
I copy him every day who are those guys
uh I just did hot yoga recently with the
in it was lovely who's that guy I don't
know why do you have specific names on
that guy who's that guy
all right fine Ricky that guy looks like
a Ricky how many youtubers can you name
no idea Tyler Oakley somebody somebody
somebody
I think that's grace Helbig somebody
somebody who's that Fred I think that's
Fred zoom in on that me cuz I'm editing
this one that's Fred that's pooty-poo
Smosh don't know so well uh don't know
don't know is that Marcia no idea no
idea no idea of no idea [ __ ] those guys
no idea no idea no idea no idea nope
nope nope as mr. Dawson I think how many
was that I don't know maybe twenty
something like that who's that cutie
over here I have no idea the stock photo
I don't know a youtuber who's that ah
it's Ian that's in he's got the bolt cut
I remember that's definitely in that's
John Felix some random youtuber some
random youtuber mr. Graceffa you like
YouTube God anything that we were doing
before you just pulled up Justine that
had nothing to do with a goddamn thing
that I just did alright okay okay
alright here's an undo it another one
cuz why not okay alright
green favorite animal dog favorite
school now this is more like it a
personality based quiz take the elements
of my life that are extremely boring and
everybody probably knows and then
determine my future from it favorite
class school activity
music I guess how do you spend your free
time video games isn't an option err why
is video games not an option
looking at my social media to see how
awesome I am that's me
what kind of TV shows do you watch can I
put whose line is it anyway because
literally the only TV show I ever watch
is that and stranger things and an
animate apparently because there's no
other choices here got a video games you
play there we go
I don't play horror on my own I like me
a nice good old adventure game I live in
it's not the suburbs setting see what
gender are you man favorite food chicken
and dumplings hmm there's no option for
chicken and dumplings here it's kind of
a mixture between all of these except
pure lard if you can just put me lard in
a bucket and then make it into dumpling
shapes and then maybe put a chicken in
it I won't ask what type of meat it is
that's my favorite food that one right
there meat I guess do you like pipo do i
like V pipo I need to Google what the
people is
[Music]
it was horrifying and then as soon as I
got to shoot I liked it to people I can
firmly say now that I like it to people
I don't know that is but you know this
is apparently deterministic by this quiz
is my YouTube girlfriend so let's see
what you got hang on a second oh Jesus
Oh God now there's something I can get
into I am a hundred percent down with
this kind of content this is exactly
what we're gonna get out of this channel
then I think there's an accurate choice
am I having a fever dream right now I
can't exactly remember what I was
supposed to be doing oh yes oh yes oh
yes more please more what do you got
ooh ooh I love it okay what was popular
what do you got
[Music]
under Dale under Dale undertale
undertale undertale undertale undertale
under dale uttered a lauderdale other
dale work I just we don't see eye to eye
eyes skip please goodbye
sorry sorry Jenny sorry sorry it just
[Music]
okay alright I'm gonna do a couple more
I'm gonna do one more girlfriend quiz of
one more boyfriend quiz because I don't
think the boyfriend ones have been very
good thus far so I need to find a good
you heard that right
I need to find a good boyfriend what do
you see in a girl intestines organs
literally a lot of [ __ ] like I mean I
don't want to be that I'm not saying
girls are full of [ __ ] I'm saying
literally we as a human species are are
just giant bags of [ __ ]
walking around on two legs and just
finding places to drop our inane
[ __ ] wherever we may go we're gonna
build a wall I don't care about this
funny I color I don't care about what
color is my weight is my hair red yeah
you hate it when a girl never lets me
talk because if there's one thing I need
to do its talk a lot
let's see favorite food everything no
not something elseö oh god I [ __ ] it
I'll never find love now alright what
can't you live without my computer
favorite color girl friends describe you
ha no ha strong and popular if I had
friends they'd say those exact things
and my three friends right here
Larry Moe and Curly Larry Moe and bubble
be Larry Moe and bigglesworth Larry Moen
and
and bill ffred would say that I'm hot
strong and popular what happening is the
most if you got married where would you
want to live Cincinnati Ohio in America
which is your feeb breaking job what
would you get her for her birthday
ah I'm gonna go V I'm gonna go The Price
is Right route and go for the highest
monetary value because in my opinion
that's what determines everything Bray
the gabbie show who is that I don't know
these people
I should know this I should know this
are you I don't know that I can read it
I'm going to do my very best but it's
gonna make me like okay what is it
poison what oh hi you know when
something so embarrassing
that nobody else is even around and you
are embarrassed with yours oh no I don't
know that no I I don't know no no no
that I I don't know wait hang on zoom in
on the hair
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] its Fame oh [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] with me look at this look look
at this
I'm trying to it whoa
it's just there already bring it on oh
I'm waiting I'm not going I can pause
the video oh nice
wait should I should I put on makeup too
I'm ready
bring on the emo I've been transformed
all right lay it onto me meet you
the next thing down my cheek roll acid
tears they've been burning all these
years scarring streaks forever stain
someone help me ease this pain look down
deep there
nothing there I'm hiding all my
trembling fears look deeper still into
my heart it's been torn and ripped apart
beneath the surface something lurks I
found out nothing ever works okay that
was pretty good
that was pretty good I think it's good
match but I got to do a final test here
we really got to know if this one is
gonna last
[Music]
so unfortunately I am out of time which
is sad because I thought I'd be able to
do another youtuber boyfriend quiz but I
guess fate just does not want me to find
my soul mate of the boyest variety but I
did find true love deep [ __ ] I guess to
do that how eat deep down in my heart my
stone-cold emo heart in the form of a
quiz on this stupid website so if you
want to see me do more quizzes or tests
and/or things on this stupid site then
let me know down in the comments below I
like stupid ideas because sometimes
they're the most fun to do so I hope you
enjoyed this let me know down the
comments below and thank you to
everybody that I made fun of over here
I'll put their links as well in the
description I won't forget about you or
Jenny or what's-his-face so thanks again
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
cool